hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt ein ganz schnelles rezept und
vor allem ist es ein sehr erfrischendes
rezept ich werde nämlich blaubär joghurt
eis machen und zwar ist so kleines
teilchen die man mit einem haps
verschlingen kann
und die sind wirklich super schnell
hergestellt ich brauche nur fünf zutaten
dafür und sind richtig lecker und vor
allem würde ich auch sagen so busines
eine gesunde alternative zum
gewöhnlichen eis also ich zeige euch mal
kurz die zutaten für die joghurt
brauchen wir 500 gramm joghurt dass es
jetzt ein zehnprozentiger naturjoghurt
wer möchte vier bis fünf teelöffel
puderzucker wandel extrakt eine
unbehandelte bio zitrone und 400 gramm
blaubeeren den puderzucker kann man
natürlich auch weglassen da hat man es
wirklich ganz gesund
aber wer gerne lieber ein bisschen
geschmack mit drin haben möchte nimmt
gerne etwas puderzucker
der zehnprozentige joghurt ist ganz
wichtig damit das alles auch so ein
bisschen cremig es ansonsten wird
einfach so bis jetzt so kristall ich
gehe ich den puderzucker mit zum joghurt
dann auch nochmal extrakt gerne ein
bisschen mehr da hat man mehr vanille
geschmack mit dabei und ich habe meine
reise vergessen alles griffbereit dann
ein bisschen zitronen april
das macht das ganze noch mal frischer
jetzt kommt noch ein bisschen
zitronensaft mit rein schritt mit der
kamera
jetzt werden die zutaten gut miteinander
vermischt
im prinzip alles schon vorbereitet und
nehmen jetzt hier diese eiswürfel
förmchen bei denen insbesondere die
haben hier unten so ein silikon boden
und da kann man denen später ganz gut
ausdrücken normale reifen formen gehen
natürlich auch das bekommt ihr später
nur eben die details preis die joghurt
global joghurt bei ein bisschen schwer
heraus aber so ist es auch bei den
eiswürfeln jetzt nehmt ihr euch am
besten einen teelöffel oder auch mit
tricks beutel und füllt jetzt die
förmchen so etwa drei viertel voll mit
dem joghurt und jetzt kommen hier die
blaubeeren mit rein immer eins bis zwei
blaubeeren pro förmchen hat sie je
nachdem wie groß die blaue bahn eben
auch sind
drücke ich die so ein bisschen rein und
jetzt nochmal für den sauberen abschluss
also mit einer tankkarte oder mit einem
teich aber absehen
das eis ist jetzt schon fertig
zubereitet gegen also ganz schnell jetzt
muss ich nur noch für mindestens zwei
bis drei stunden einfrieren bis eben
komplett gefroren sind
die sind jetzt eingefroren
und jetzt kann ich sie aus der form
herauslösen und wie gesagt natürlich
und wie gesagt habe ich ja die hier
diesen silikon boden und kann deswegen
die joghurt eis ich kann mich noch ein
früher ihnen da hast du das ding so
knicken müssen oder ein bisschen mit
warmem wasser auch nach sie einzelne
ausgerichtet genau also habt ja aber es
geht
kraft ich muss auch ehrlich sagen das
war für mich so ein bisschen
überraschungs rezept von allen rezepten
jetzt bei galileo weil ich finde einfach
sie sich nicht zu süß das ist so
meisterhaft doch kein schlechtes
gewissen
vor allem kann man halt auch gut
vorbereiten und es ist wie wenn man den
zucker zum beispiel weglässt aufzeigen
und ich habe jetzt echt wenig zucker
drin aber ich fand es klasse dass kaupat
runter also man kann sie auch ruhig fünf
minuten draußen stehen lassen
das hatten sie auf jeden fall aus je
nachdem wie temperatur zu hause ist
alles so richtig erfrischend und du hast
dich kein so schlechtes gewissen
henderson und ich finde es kaum machen
und dann immer mal wieder ins
tiefkühlfach geht nun einmal waschen
das ist schon richtig winter geschmack
das hat so eine kopfnote und zu unserem
kopf geschmack finde ich dass das läuft
runter oder macht eine aufstellung okay
aber richtig gut wenn du dich in der
kamera vor der kamera zeigen wir das für
dich jetzt eine bauchbinde machen morath
sternekoch was was heißt es braucht wenn
ihr müsst mich jetzt hinten drin da
jetzt braucht westlichen ganz anderen
für mich ganz andere bedeutung wenn ich
nicht durchs naja also jedenfalls wenn
ich dieses rezept wirklich geniale
superschnell gemacht in fünf minuten
vorbereitet und dann hat man wirklich
was richtig tolles gezaubert und dieser
miranda es auch gerne also eine richtig
coole geburtstag
total lecker also falls ihr dieses
rezept nach machen wollte als ich meinen
viele zutaten war sitzt nicht trotzdem
schreibe ich natürlich auf meinem blog
da findet ist noch mal ganz genau und
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß das
nachmachen und vor allen dingen müsst
ihr nicht glauben nehmen ihr könnt auch
erdbeeren nehmen und die klein schneiden
himbeeren alles was innerhalb kevins bei
heidelberg wir tragen bereit machen für
mal gespannt wer das alles versteht